[Music]
swanny i welcome you to sharing and
networking session organised by the PDA
and our international partner the Danish
Design Centre the Danish design award
run by the centre has the same goals as
actually the PDA which is really to
celebrate the impact of design to see
designers and enabler and a solution to
complex social economic issues the theme
of this exhibition and talk is actually
titled
tech that makes a difference designing
for social group of Technology and sees
a solid panel of award winning designers
from both PD and DDA and the outstanding
outcomes of design that made a powerful
impact the in MO is a pillow or a
cushion a place music it's adaptive
music and the important part is the
person's suffering from dementia who get
into trouble because they cannot
communicate they lose their language and
they lose whatever quality of life they
might have and it gets increasingly hard
to find out how to make their life just
a little bit better as a care person if
you work with persons with dementia you
say ten good minutes a day are ten
minutes that weren't bad it seems to
create another way a be a medium for
contact between people who have a hard
time reaching each other not only people
suffering from dementia but also normal
persons like you and I who may not have
the language we need to communicate
about what is hard but we could share a
moment together with stuff like this
one third of all food that's produced in
the world is being wasted eight percent
of the greenhouse gas emissions is
actually derived from the food that we
waste the social factor which makes you
also think about the absurdity of the
problem since we produce more than
enough food to feed everyone in the
world yet 870 million people they still
go to bed hungry every night so the
solution that we have is one where you
get a big bucks or back so that's what
we call a magic bag with all the surplus
food that's left at the end of the day
and the reason why it's called the magic
bag is you don't know exactly what
you're gonna get from it they actually
really like them because then that's the
highlight of the day to see oh what am I
gonna get in the tribute to go bag you
order through the app and then you go
and pick up the food thirty minutes or
fifteen minutes before closing time and
that's it I think that's actually a very
very simple way to fight a very complex
problem and a Coe of that is to inspire
and empower everyone to take action
against food waste and that's much more
important because then we actually bring
some awareness to how big this problem
is
when did we actually start and it was
actually when we were approached by GE
Healthcare said well we have this very
interesting idea we want to bring
ultrasound to a lot of people who don't
have access to such a device we were
very keen to investigate and find out
what was happening in those spaces so
with all that information we kind of
went through pretty much what we do as
designers going through that practice of
research I da ting problem solving
bringing a group of stakeholders
together this is essentially a full
gamut of expertise around the table we
had developers we had program managers
one of the key factors that we were
looking at is how do you actually take
away it's not what you put in but what
can we remove from this device to make
it as simple and as easy as possible to
use without dumbing it down to the point
where it's not no longer effective and
what we were able to achieve was
something that is context sensitive so
it changes according to how you're using
it and the beauty of a device like this
is that it starts to give you some
analysis and calculations so that you
can identify whether the fetus is
growing properly or whether there's some
anomalies that you need to take care of
and I wanted to touch on this concept of
design for impact of course you need to
have a vision you need to be clear on
what you're trying to achieve and I
think that very much needs to be
supported by ground-up research but
above all I think it's the commitment
it's the commitment from the client side
to keep going through this as a
commitment from everyone on the team so
I had a check in with the GE team
literally this morning just to see how
things are going with this product
they've now shift over 2000 devices many
of them in Africa and Nigeria Ethiopia
in Ghana this device is actually being
requested in developed markets where
it's portability its ease of use is also
proving to be very very effective and
this is literally in their email today
we continue to get good feedback about
the design of the product the
portability battery operation and simple
touchscreen UI are the most appreciated
qualities and that makes me very happy
puts a smile on my face so really glad
to have been part of this project
you